before we get to how can we protect
people
how can people protect themselves how
can you get the parasite out of yourself
that's a great question so it really it
so anything that i'm going to say in
answering that question
how do we how do we inoculate ourselves
against this how do we vaccinate
ourselves against if we're already
parasitized how do we cure ourselves
that rests on one single
you know a priory tenet and that is that
you are
at least open to
my evidence right so so if you just go
la la la la la my ears and i'm not gonna
listen
then there's absolutely you're
impenetrable there's no way for me it's
kind of like saying
you'd like to benefit from the vaccine
but you're too scared of the needle
and therefore you i can't give you that
right well hydra
so so once we agree that you are
open to the vaccine then here is how
there are several things that we can do
but let me discuss the
the the biggest one so there is a thing
in chapter seven of my book which i call
homological networks of cumulative
evidence
now this originally comes from my work
in evolutionary psychology actually
which i now apply to this context so
homological networks of cumulative
evidence is the idea that if i'm trying
to convince you
of an explanation let's say a scientific
explanation
i have to start thinking this way what
would be the data
that i would need to show you that
becomes so
unassailable that even the most dogged
the tractor will be drowned in a sea of
evidence right
now as someone you're in britain correct
correct
right so charles darwin if you'd like is
perhaps the most famous example of
someone who was thinking
synthetically in this way synthetically
meaning putting a whole bunch of stuff
together
creating conciliance unity of knowledge
now he didn't use the term nomological
networks of cumulative evidence but
that's exactly what he was doing because
in
demonstrating that his theory of natural
selection
was vertical was correct what did he do
he assiduously over many decades
collected data
from an incredible number of sources
from paleontology
from animal husbandry from embryology
from comparative anatomy
from geology and each of these small
pieces of the puzzle
once you put the whole thing together
made it impossible for you to argue
against it
despite the fact that 150 years later
people are still trying to falsify it
without being able to right and so i
take this
mindset and i formalize it in this thing
called neurological networks of
cumulative evidence
maybe if i give you a specific example
it will help
explain okay so let's suppose i want to
show i want to prove to you
that toy preferences are not due to
social construction
in other words it's not just mommy and
daddy are sexist pigs
and they teach little johnny to play
with the truck and little linda to play
you know with the doll right in other
words there is something beyond the
social constructivist argument
how would i go about demonstrating this
to you so now what i'm going to do
is i'm going to say can i get data from
different cultures
different time periods different
paradigms different disciplines
different methodologies all of which
point to the same incontrovertible
final conclusion well so i'll just do a
few okay
well i can look at children who are
in the pre-socialization stage of their
cognitive development
meaning they're too young to have been
socialized they're
three months old they're six months old
and i could study
their sex specific toy preferences now
you might say well how would you elicit
their preference
they can't speak yet they're three or
six months old well you can do it
through eye gaze you could do it through
how they
what do they go towards and what you
show
is that children who are in the
pre-socialization cognitive
developmental stage
are already exhibiting the sex-specific
toy preferences that we then see in
later children
now if i already stopped there i'm
already giving you
evidence that is slowly you know making
the cot you know the nail in the coffin
but i'm gonna give you a lot more okay
if you take little girls who suffer from
congenital adrenal hyperplasia
which is an endocrinological disorder
that
masculinizes their morphology and
masculinizes
their behavior so little girls who
suffer from this disorder
are more boy-like and we take this
group of little girls and look at their
toy preferences
what do you think happens to their toy
preferences they are reversed they're
exactly like those of boys
so now i've given you two data sets i've
given you data sets from developmental
psychology
and i've now given you data from
pediatrics from pediatric endocrinology
now already the social constructivist
thing should be in the dustbin of
[ __ ] history right
but let's go on i could look at other
species
vervet monkeys rhesus monkeys
chimpanzees
to see whether the infants in those
species exhibit the same
sex specificity in toy preferences and
guess what my man
they do well you'd have to argue that
mama vervet monkey and papa vervet
monkey
are prone to the same patriarchal sexist
influences that we see in humans right
so now i've given you if you like three
boxes of the
nomological network bit by bit i will
drown you in evidence
so that it becomes very difficult for
you to stick to your position
so what i try to then argue to people
that
epistemology that i just described need
not only apply to scientific arguments
or to
evolutionary based arguments it could
apply to
any phenomenon that has a lot of
contentious debate around it so
the example that i give in the book the
sort of the final example in chapter
seven is
is islam a peaceful religion or not
now i don't need to get into hysteria i
don't need to listen to noble prophet
barack obama telling me that it is
peaceful or not
i simply need to build an homological
network and if that neurological network
says that islam is peaceful
then we've proven that it's peaceful if
it says otherwise
then we've proven otherwise so i don't
need hysteria
i don't need emotionality i don't need
to trigger my affective system
i simply go where the data tells me to
go
does that give you a good sense of how
to get vaccinated against bs it does
but is that an effort that people have
to do individually so have i got to go
and do this literature review where i
scour the internet and i look at this
stuff and is that a veritable source and
so on and so forth
so that's a great question in a sense
it's a slightly less
extreme version of putting my ears in my
right because what you're saying is okay
even if i don't
even if i'm open to listening to you do
i have the cognitive
uh desire most of the most of the
the um effort for me to protect myself
potentially from one of these ideas
is that on me to go out and
search for this much stuff or is is
there some platform are there some
particular voices
have you got a book yes so so one of the
one of the projects that i'm currently
working on and i just published an
academic paper on exactly that
so one of the ideas that i have is to
have
something akin to a wikipedia platform
where
what is it it's true i'm not this is not
a joke this is really i know it's not a
joke but it's funny
i've got a question i've got a question
coming up that that this relates to so
i'm going to let you go and then i'm
going to give
i'm going to give you the question so
but now what i'm gonna say is specific
only to evolutionary psychology so it's
not to any debate
so one of the one of the things that i
find most
galling when imbeciles argue against
evolutionary psychology
sorry i don't mean to say imbeciles
that's not diplomatic
people with a differing opinion also
known as
lobotomized idiots right so
they will say things like well you know
bro evolutionary psychology it's
pseudoscience
uh yeah you're a [ __ ] the mind
didn't come from magic it didn't arise
through
a magical cultural process culture
exists in its form
because of biology not instead of
biology socialization matters but
socialization is not something
in lieu of biology it's because of
biology
so unless you unless you think that
everything in our body is due to
evolution short of the
organ that most defines our personhood
this thing called the human mind
then there is no such thing as
evolutionary psychology pseudoscience
now you can argue
that this particular study in
evolutionary psychology did not meet the
evidentiary threshold that i like
for me to be convinced but that's also
true when astrophysicists are deciding
whether the universe is expanding or
contracting
so the fact that you we may debate about
specifics and evolutionary theory or
evolutionary psychology
doesn't imply that the epistemological
exercise of evolution psychology
is false it's pseudoscience to say that
evolutionary psychology is pseudoscience
is like saying chemistry is
pseudoscience
there is no other game in town if you
believe that the human mind
evolved through material processes it's
not god who put it
there is no other game in town right so
to come back to the earlier wikipedia
point
so one of the things that i i'm trying
to do here is to
if you like counter the most
common criticism of evolutionary
psychology that comes from
fellow academics and usually it is that
evolutionary psychology
is just a bunch of fanciful just so
storytelling right so i sit around
i put on my sexy very white music i i'm
smoking
a pipe sipping some cognac and i just
come up with some [ __ ]
quantification as to why men
and as i showed you a few minutes ago no
when i want to prove to you that toy
preferences
are sex specific for an evolutionary
reason i actually go through
incredible length to do so much more so
than other sciences
so in my attempt to thwart this i
thought well
if i can get more people to think along
the ways of gnomological networks
and start building these like a wisdom
of the crowd where
we can build together so if you want to
go see what is the current state of
cumulative evidence to prove that men
have a
preference for the hourglass figure you
can go to that wikipedia of normological
networks and see it